well we have certainly had a lot of
Fantastic Four News these past few
months but the Fantastic Four official
cast has been locked in Marvel Studios
has the official fantastic forecast for
the film and I specifically say that
because right now the reports just state
that we have the team the family the
Fantastic 4 meaning as far as we know
right now the only members of the film
that have been cast are Mr Fantastic The
Invisible Woman the thing and the Human
Torch galatis is reportedly going to be
the villain of this film no news on
official casting for him yet and the
Silver Surfer is supposed to be the
herald of Galactus with reports stating
that this is going to be a female
version of the Silver Surfer but of
course everybody's biggest question is
when is Marvel themselves going to
officially announce the cast well
according to a recent report less than 2
weeks so let's break down everything you
need to know in this video plus talk
about that Deadpool 3 trailer so be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest videos about the MCU
and we're doing a big giveaway giving
away of PS5 and Xbox series X more about
that at the end of the video so this
report is coming from John campia John
campia has been in the industry for a
very long time he knows a lot of people
he's broken Scoops before and of course
a lot of people remember that he
accidentally posted a very real leaked
picture of the three Spider-Man from
Spider-Man know home right before the
movie came out so clearly Jon has
connections and he knows things and
yesterday during his show he said that
by the end of next week we will have the
Fantastic forecast now two things worth
noting here one is that before he said
that he said he is not going to say why
he is saying that which most people have
interpreted as I cannot reveal my
sources or they're going to get in
trouble I can't say how I know because
if I do then Marvel's going to find out
and perhaps the person who told me could
get in trouble and he obviously doesn't
want that then he kind of ended the
conversation by saying that's what I'm
calling by the end of next week almost
seeming like he is trying to cover it up
a little bit that way when slash if the
cast does get announced by the end of
next week he doesn't get anybody in
trouble now here's the thing John campia
and what he says on a show gets posted
on Twitter a lot Instagram Reddit
wherever he's very aware that people
watch his show and take what he says
seriously so he really shouldn't have
any reason to say this unless he truly
One Believes it and two knows it it
seems like he has clearly heard
something that makes him confident
enough to say this on his show in front
of everybody where he knows it's going
to be reported so he's confident enough
with what he heard to state that by the
end of next week we'll have the official
fantastic forecast and this really does
line up with basically what we've been
hearing recently Matt shackman who is
the director of the new Fantastic 4
movie has spoken up about this in the
past couple of months he's been stating
that he can't wait to tell everybody who
the official fantastic forecast is he
simply couldn't yet and this was due to
several reasons one was the strikes they
couldn't do anything official during the
strikes and that included actually
locking down the cast getting official
contracts out there and signing those
contracts to make it official that could
not happen during the strikes but as
soon as the strikes were over it seems
like Marvel and Matt shackman contacted
the actors that they wanted for the
roles and it seems seems like everything
went relatively smoothly Pedro Pascal
was signed on to play Mr Fantastic
really not too long after the strikes
ended and it sounds like based off of
everything that we've heard so far about
the Fantastic 4 there has been one
decent consistency throughout this whole
entire thing and that is the casting of
Vanessa Kirby as Sue storm AKA The
Invisible Woman I'm sure everybody
remembers what it was like for Mr
Fantastic there were a ton of names
being thrown out there it seems like
every other week for an actor who was
supposedly going to play Mr Fantastic it
was Adam Driver for the longest time
then it was Ryan Gosling then it was
Jake Gyllenhaal which would have been
weird but again if the Fantastic 4 film
does take place in another universe that
might have worked maybe then we got
reports from the major outlets and the
Insiders in our community all confirming
the same thing Pedro Pascal has been
offered the role and has accepted the
role of Mr Fantastic in the Fantastic 4
that was a roller coaster but what
hasn't been a roller coaster is Vanessa
Kirby and yes there were a lot of names
thrown out in the beginning but since
they started announcing that Vanessa
Kirby is our Sous storm there hasn't
been any contradicting reports no other
names for Su storm have been thrown out
there since we've heard the reports that
Vanessa Kirby is Su storm now not too
long ago we heard that she hadn't
exactly officially locked in yet but she
had the offer from Marvel everything was
just waiting to be finalized and now
apparently it seems like it has been
finalized so as far as we're concerned
right now it's Pedro Pascal and Vanessa
Kirby as Mr Fantastic and The Invisible
Woman an earlier report stated that in
this film they were already going to be
married and Kevin feige does this
sometimes he just jumps into a project
stating well we know the origin story
already and in fact he's already
mentioned about the Fantastic 4 that
it's not going to be the stereotypical
origin story that we're used to with the
Fantastic 4 and I got to say having them
come from a different Universe to our
universe that would be pretty original
if executed properly now as far as the
thing is concerned it's kind of just
rumors and speculation at this point but
the last name that was thrown out was
Ebon Moss Bakr who has worked with
Marvel before in The Punisher Series so
that would make sense also keep in mind
the thing is probably going to be mostly
CGI if not a bodysuit but I'm guessing
the same CGI techniques that they've
used for the Hulk and as far as the
Human Torch is concerned the last we've
heard is stranger things actor Joseph
Quinn which a lot of people seem to be
really for but the thing and the Human
Torch the actors for those roles are
kind of Uncertain right now could be
these two it might be two completely
different actors but we'll have to wait
hopefully not longer than the end of
next week according to John campia to
find out the official cast now about the
Deadpool 3 trailer I've gotten a lot of
questions about it possibly being
delayed I guess that is a rumor going
around online I hadn't heard that rumor
but I did see that The Insider cryptic
HD quality posted this on Twitter I
don't know what this talk about Deadpool
trailer being delayed is but I don't
think it's true can confir confirm a
trailer is currently being prepared and
yes I still call it Twitter I'm aware
that it's X but it's probably always
going to be Twitter for me but cryptic
HD quality has an impeccable track
record when it comes to Scoops that
account is very accurate so I believe
what they say a trailer is being
prepared now what we've heard is that
it's probably going to Premiere during
the Super Bowl which makes a lot of
sense it is the perfect opportunity for
Marvel and from what we've heard
recently Marvel has put so much faith in
Deadpool three so much faith that people
in the industry are now saying that it's
going to completely revive Marvel and
save Marvel save their brand and the
fans they believe it or we want to at
least but it's really hard to think that
Ryan Reynolds Hugh Jackman Shan Levy and
Kevin feige would make a bad Deadpool
movie especially if you consider
everything we've heard about it with the
X-Men and the other cameos appearing in
the film and the Multiverse traveling
and the Wolverine variants and the
Deadpool variants and I've been saying
this from the beginning even just a
movie with Ryan reynolds's Deadpool and
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine would
absolutely be enough for us to lose our
minds now luckily the film is really
going to focus on the two of them but
we're going to get a lot of other
awesome stuff put in there as well plus
not to mention this film is going to
directly set up Avengers Secret Wars so
a lot of Hope for Deadpool 3 a lot of
hope that the trailer is indeed going to
come on the Super Bowl now Marvel
Studios does have a track record of
airing trailers during the Super Bowl it
is very Marvel fashion of them so right
now I'm expecting it to happen during
the Super Bowl but if we hear anything
else we'll let you know so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest news let us know your thoughts
about all of this in the comments down
below do you like Pedra Pascal and
Vanessa Kirby as Mr Fantastic and The
Invisible Woman and who would you like
to see play the thing and the Human
Torch please don't forget to like this
video And subscribe and if you subscribe
and leave a comment you are
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series
X some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets pick one item and
we pick one winner at the end of each
month you can find us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
woof